I wanna talk about something pretty big here.
A potential breakthrough in tackling the most common form of dementia.
It's a new drug being praised for its ability...
...to slow the effects of Alzheimer's on the brain.
Tell us more about this.
Yeah, Joe and Savannah, this is breaking news...
...published in the New England Journal of Medicine...
...and it signals that we're getting ever closer,...
...but probably not close enough for patient's comfort.
This is a new medication that showed a significant decrease in dementia.
It did have some side effects but it was something that had positive results...
...in the trial to be significant enough, not just for Alzheimer's, dementia,...
...possibly for other dementias.
There is some important kind of development in anatomy...
..that we see in patients with dementia in a plaque that can develop...
...around the nervous system that shows that people might be more at risk...
...or have significant dementia.
And this particular drug was developed, Lecanemab,...
...and it was partnership between the company Biogen and Eisai Pharmaceutical.
So, this was a kind of a partnership of two very well-known CNS drug manufacturers.
Here is the short kind of version, though.
Savannah and Joe, we're not gonna necessarily see this result right away...
...for dementia patients today, but hopefully we'll have signals for the future...
...and some solutions in the end.
We'll take all the promising news we can get on that.
Yeah, we can.